[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a comedy drama film
called hitchco
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
nina is a woman in her 20s looking to
get a job as a teacher she has a
bachelor's degree in education and a
master's degree in science making her
the perfect candidate academically
however her biggest drawback in life is
that she has tourette's syndrome this
causes her to make uncontrollable noises
that sound like hiccups
since she can hardly keep quiet because
of it the interviewers believe that she
is unfit to be a teacher nina has been
trying to get a job for the past five
years but with no luck she is now
working as a freelance animator but
hasn't given up on finding a job as a
teacher nina lives with her mother and
younger brother vinay both of whom
support her unconditionally a flashback
shows us that when nina was in middle
school she used to be made fun of all
the time
the teachers didn't understand that her
condition was uncontrollable and sent
her outside the class whenever she made
a noise this had a huge effect on her
mental health and she could hardly make
friends she was transferred from 12
schools and was told to go to school for
children with special needs but nina's
mother suda was adamant about giving her
daughter a normal life the same cannot
be said for her father sachin he
divorced suda after finding out that
naina had tourettes and was never
present for the first few years of her
life he tried to bond with his children
over the years but every time they went
out he was so embarrassed of naina he
also urged suda to send her to a special
needs school but she didn't give up on
her daughter the day nina found out that
her parents divorced because of her she
shoved toilet paper into her mouth to
try to prevent the noises she wanted to
be liked by her father so badly that she
blamed herself for not being good enough
currently sachin does his best to be
present in his children's lives but nina
doesn't welcome him he doesn't support
her dreams and wants her to take an easy
banking job
one day they get into an argument about
the matter when suddenly nina gets a
call from her former school saint
notchers they ask her to come in for a
second interview claiming that she has
gotten the job a high school teacher at
saint nautker resigned mid-term leaving
the school's board desperate for a new
candidate although nano is not their
first choice they had to hire her for
the time being she goes for a follow-up
interview with the dean and fellow
teachers they are all skeptical because
of obvious reasons but nina's spirit
impresses them when asked why she wants
to be a teacher she replies that after
being kicked out of 12 schools she was
accepted by saint nadkers all thanks to
her former teacher mr ali a flashback
shows us little naina watching a drama
performance during a school function
while everyone in the audience watches
in silence she cannot help but make a
noise because of her tourettes
they look at her annoyed when the
school's principal mr ali calls her to
the stage he makes her explain her
condition to the audience and asks her
what they can do to help her after
listening to her story the teachers of
the school understand her condition much
better and help her accordingly back in
the interview she praises mr ali
claiming that she wants to be a teacher
because of him impressed with the answer
the dean welcomes her to the school but
a fellow teacher named wadia bluntly
declares that it is a bad decision
the dean shows nina around the school
and tells her that she is supposed to
teach class 9f the students with you
guessed it the worst grades in the
school on her first day at the job nina
goes to the auditorium reminiscing about
the day she was called to the stage the
students of class 9f enter the room but
do not notice her they talk in foul
street language and start smoking
cigarettes some of them play with their
pet mice while the others play cards
they also talk about nina calling her
names and making fun of her hiccups like
turrets nina hears them but doesn't
confront them later she meets the
students for the first time and welcomes
them to her class like she had thought
they make fun of her hiccups and call
her names their leader atish makes
inappropriate comments about wanting to
call nina at night still when the
students laugh she laughs with them not
showing that her words affect her she
also explains to them what tourette's is
the students realized that she heard
their conversation earlier and go quiet
but moments later they burst into
laughter when naina falls from a broken
chair while trying to sit on it during
the lunch break one of the school's top
scoring students akshay gets into an
argument with atish about a punctured
football they get into a fight but only
attish is taken to the dean's office the
following day nina meets the school's
janitor and asks him the history of
class 9f ah the janitor the center of
wisdom at any public school she finds
out that everyone in class 9f lives in a
nearby slum in poverty they were granted
admission to the prestigious school
because their old municipal school was
under heavy debt they had been promised
good education but instead they faced
prejudice from the teachers and the
wealthy students with time they
retaliated and became the people they
are today after finding out the truth
nina is determined to help them even
more but the students do not cooperate
they never pay attention when she is
teaching and prank her every day one
time they even go as far as to paste her
picture and phone number around the
neighborhood advertising her as a sex
worker when nina walks into the class
the next morning she sees a bucket on
looking closer it explodes and breaks
the glass window the students are about
to be expelled from the school because
of the pranks but nina takes the blame
on herself claiming that the explosion
was her fault she asks the dean to give
them one more chance when he tells her
that the kids have no future nina
insists that if they do not score good
results on the final exam she will admit
that she was wrong and the students will
be expelled the dean agrees and gives
her four months time to prove herself
following that she comes to the
classroom to the students who are
grateful that she helped them it is
foreign to them because no teacher of
the school had treated them with respect
until now starting the next day the
students pay attention to when she
teaches and get along with her nina uses
various innovative techniques to keep
them entertained she even holds classes
on the ground and throws boiled eggs at
them to explain about a parabola all
this time wadia watches her unimpressed
by her teaching techniques he is hoping
for her downfall because he despises the
students of 9f in one of the classes the
students complain that they are never
considered for eligibility to be in the
school's prefects team nina takes their
concern to the dean and is told that a
student has to score more than 90
percent to be eligible wadia laughs at
the thought of her students scoring that
high but nina takes on the challenge the
next week the school holds a parent
teacher meeting while all other teachers
are busy talking to the parents nina
sits idle the entire time since the
parents of the students in 9f are busy
trying to make minimum wage daily they
hardly get time to be involved in their
children's lives nina takes it upon
herself to go to the slums and meet the
parents the lifestyle of the people
living there makes her realize why the
students have such a hard time focusing
on their studies the kids and their
parents have to wait in line for hours
just to get a bucket of water the family
barely earns enough to make a living let
alone to invest on better stationaries
for their kids in the next class nina
asks the kids to write down a list of
things they are scared of after they are
done she asks them to use the list as a
way of letting go of the fear she brings
in a bogart and
wrong movie the students tear the pages
and make paper airplanes with them wadia
finds one of the papers and laughs at
what is written on it nina teaches the
students in a way that actually
interests them even the students of
class 9a are jealous of the fun
experiments that she lets the children
perform wadia and his students are
preparing a project for the national
science fair saint natker has won the
last two years hence wadia is hoping for
a third win one day the topper natasha
invites atish and the group to give them
a tour of their project by this time the
students of 9f are just as good in their
studies as the others they even suggest
innovative changes that could be done to
the project however when wadia finds out
they are messing with it he insults a
tish calling him a mere bicycle mechanic
later atish says offensive things to
akshay in order to pick a fight with him
they almost hit each other and have to
be separated by naina atish calls her an
animal from a circus making fun of her
tourettes nina almost hits him but
controls herself that evening she goes
to dinner with her family for her
brother's birthday her father sachin
orders for her when she takes the time
to do so because of her tourettes it is
clear that he is embarrassed by her
which causes tension between the two yet
again the next day akshay presents their
project to the school teachers to
practice for the science fair however
the working model explodes in the middle
of it wadia apologizes to everyone for
the inconvenience disappointed that they
do not have enough time to prepare a new
model on checking what is wrong with the
model he finds a vial of glue that he
had seen with atish earlier it is clear
that atish messed with the model to
destroy it when he is called out for it
the entire class joins him claiming that
they helped him do it even though it was
only his plan the dean is about to expel
the entire class now that they have
crossed the line but nina begs for him
to let them take the exam because their
future depends on it in the end they are
suspended from attending school until
the exams the students are furious at a
tish for breaking nina's trust
that night they gather by the bank of a
river and decide that even if they
cannot go to school they will study hard
for the exams and make their teacher
proud the next day they visit nina and
apologize for everything they have done
until now sachin sees this and is proud
of his daughter for the first time in
his life he also starts to respect her
as a person realizing that he was in
fact ashamed of her until now too little
too late douche dad for the next few
weeks the students do nothing but study
nina invites them to her house almost
every day for group studies she also
provides them with required stationaries
preparing them for the exam the day
before the exam the school's janitor
offers to sell the question papers to
atish he buys it from him and tries to
give it to the others however they do
not want to cheat because that would
mean betraying naina the morning of the
exam atish realizes that the question
papers he was provided with more fake
still the students do their best and
score passing marks one of them named
uru scores the highest marks surpassing
everyone even from class 9a on doing
some digging wadia finds out about the
leaked question papers and accuses
everyone from 9f of cheating the janitor
affirms that he sold the papers the dean
cannot excuse their actions anymore he
decides to expel everyone from the class
in the morning assembly the students
apologized to nina for letting her down
but insist that they did not cheat nina
believes them but she has no way to
prove the same to the others then we see
akshay and wadia walking down the
hallway akshay reveals that he was the
one who sent the janitor to sell atish
the fake question papers he hopes that
wadia will be proud of him but instead
he looks at him in disappointment in the
morning assembly the students are
nervous about being expelled but to
their surprise wadia apologizes for not
believing in class 9f and claims that he
sent the janitor with the fake question
paper he wants to save his student as
nina did for 9f in the end the students
are brought to the stage and two of them
are given the prefect badges a year
later the school takes part in the
national science fair competition the
students collectively take part in it
and win the first prize
cut to 25 years later nina is now the
principal of the school it is her last
day as a teacher before retiring when
she walks out she meets the former 9f
members who have all grown into
successful adults the movie ends as they
reunite subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching